with this story from Snopes from a few
days ago did a church that Embraces
lgbtq plus people burned down after a
lightning strike was this climate change
white supremacy exactly lightning is
very white that was absolutely white
supremacy good point
actually saying the gray hair and the
beard the Trident that proves all the
markings so irrefutable as as sort of a
buffer between culture War and the fact
that the air is unsafe to breathe we we
had this story and uh was it you that
brought it up Sheamus or was it Ian oh
no I brought it up I saw that on my news
feed I started laughing I was like is
this real and then so it was this guy
Eric says woke lgbtq plus Church gets
struck by lightning and burns to the
ground oh my God and Snopes did a fact
check and guess what it did get struck
by lightning it did burn to the ground
it did support lgbtq issues but they
won't write true on it would it be
hilarious if they actually were
fact-checking the claim specifically
that it happened because it was a
punishment from God and they were like
fact check true we have to admit it this
is it's true this time we'll give them
that and then objective normally you
know Snopes will be like true thing
happened false mostly false in this
article it says oh okay so it's from
today actually did a church that
Embraces lgbtq plus people burned on
after a lightning strike the answer is
yes it did it quite literally did now
that's not to say God literally struck
the church down but Snopes won't even
write true here
yeah so uh they say it's not sort of an
explanation on June 6 a viral tweet with
a video of a church building fire began
to receive thousands of engagements the
caption of the Tweet read woke lgbtq
plus chariots get struck by lightning
and burns to the ground in the story
we've let out the facts they say Okay
blah blah blah they say the Tweet was
captured June 2nd the church did Embrace
uh the these issues over the past
several years so that's that's all you
really need to understand and of course
they don't want the narrative to be that
a thing like this did happen do you guys
remember when the George Floyd mural
exploded yes
I gotta tell you man I mean you know I
gotta say twice I don't know
yeah but stuff like this might happen
all the time also like right right and
like no no the question is how do you
determine whether it's something Beyond
or something just well I think you also
have to look at I mean look to be
rational for a second which is boring I
mean it looks like a pretty rural area
it might have just been the tallest
building in town with a steeple yeah
which would have logically attracted the
lightning
which is to me has been a problem for
the conservative moon for you that's a
whole other show I think that uh there
is something to be said for this right
because obviously we're sort of being
facetious about this lightning or this
mural being struck by lightning and the
church being struck by lightning I don't
know about that mural but I will say
well I'll I'll say this that was like
flat I think and I I think this specific
thing got struck by lightning as
actually a more convincing argument than
the weather is vaguely changing so we're
gonna blame X Y and Z you you actually
have a specific Target there so it makes
more sense to make the argument
you have a very complicated argument
that consistently morphs to to fit
whatever the left's political views are
and then you have does God smite
that George Floyd thing I don't know man
this is why so you'll see George Floyd
but not this church for shame Tim I
think well because buildings get struck
by lightning no the George Floyd mural
was a flat brick wall and right only
thing that exploded Off the Wall was the
picture of just George Floyd and it was
like one small storm cloud floating over
and went yeah
we need to do a survey to find if lgbtq
churches get struck by lightning more
often if they do if they do then
absolutely so anecdotally I went to
Burning Man and there's there's at the
end of The Burning Man week you there's
the temple that everyone like puts their
their old thoughts and feelings they all
like notes from dead loved ones things
they want to like let go of and grieve
over they put him in the temple and the
temple the energy at the temple when you
go to the temple is just like siphoning
up and it's just it was tough to get
near that place and I was tripping so it
could be I could be out of my mind but I
think there might be something too like
honing energy into physical objects
complete anecdotal nonsense of course
religions from time immemorial talk
about it you know imbuing uh an idol and
things like that and cultures have
sacrificed children to the weather yep
for Millennia yep I think people are
known to have called lightning is that
like what if like it turns out that you
actually do have to sacrifice your kids
to to Malik to stop the weather from
going back but I'll tell you stranger
things stranger things are happening
around us man let's face it if these
crazy things started happening would
anybody be really that surprised at this
point like oh my God this can't happen
at this point I'm pretty sure if the
ground split a fissure emerged in DC
with like lava bubbling up and and Malik
emerged eyes people would be like huh
that doesn't necessarily have anything
to do with the fact that it is
Washington DC Mala could have Arisen
anywhere with this church lightning
strike I would believe more that it's a
directed energy weapon from like space
than it is God why I had to but like who
would do it though as a directed uh and
NY pics
from Massachusetts it's your target of
opportunity right so division you know
you wanna you wanna set people on their
heels censor Massachusetts or the church
yeah
Putin is like we must Target Spencer I'm
gonna listen
but it turns out the church is actually
like a covert CIA yeah
once at a massage parlor or something
like that well I think we can take this
a step further the reason this church
was struck by lightning was because of
climate change which is the fault of
Republicans therefore this is a hate
crime boom I'm just gonna blame it on
Liz Warren yeah
when did this it's always a safe bet
yeah it gets struck today or yesterday
it was after the wildflowers from this
room June 2nd someone super chatted uh
John Fisher saying there's a set there's
satellite footage showing all the fires
in Canada starting at the exact same
time totally not suspect
seeing this online now too people are
saying that yeah yeah I just got that
tweeted at me
so they're implying that someone has
some kind of space laser that they can
use to start fires with or like a
temporal that seems silly temporal
critical mass temporal is that the right
word temperature wise critical mass like
it hit a certain temperature and then
everything got really flammable at like
96 degrees you'd have to have like a
very very powerful laser in space to be
able to hit the Earth with that kind of
you know to start a fire but I will tell
you guys something another anecdote
about 12 years ago I was outside of
Vegas so I said Let me Take a Ride by
the that area you know Area 51 and those
entrances there's a couple little
businesses there and I'm talking to a
guy as a local maybe a hundred people
live around there and the guy was a
normal rational guy he worked in Vegas
for the casinos and all you know
contractor and I said to him joking I
said oh do you guys see UFOs he goes no
no that's all nonsense he said but you
gotta see sometimes you'll sit out here
in these energy weapons he said it would
blow your mind some of the stuff we see
him test only because you can't avoid it
right it's just this big vast area is
and against the contrasted dark sky so
the capability is certainly there I mean
if you need you know the military hasn't
been shy about alluding to the fact that
these things exist at this point we have
space force right uh clearly we didn't
make space force a branch of the
military to do research and Horticulture
you know 18 000 you know miles up or
whatever it is how many miles up we are
so there's definitely something to that
I mean I got to believe we've got
weapons floating around up there you
know and we just said Canada set it too
good for too long we're gonna they
really have come on they've been like a
very like actually I don't know about
that is not the Canadians it's the trees
uh the trees the trees they're upset
about the CO2 the trees were saying some
naughty words and hate speaking words
yeah yeah those ants we hear about
Lockheed Martin's compact Fusion reactor
they started this program in 2010 uh is
a fusion power project at Lockheed
Martin's Skunk Works and so if they're
public about a fusion program what
aren't they public yes and how much
energy can they actually direct probably
oh dude I saw I saw a tour of a nuclear
submarine just on the news and I'm just
like okay if if they're publicly sure
what do we have we got something way
crazier yeah think about it right we
found out about the stealth fighter not
the bomber not the B2 the F-117 that
Nighthawk somewhere in like the late 80s
early 90s right that thing was
operational since 1978. we found out
about that 12 13 years later so who
knows people probably thought it was
aliens they probably did they did they
certainly did right and the B2 so what
in the world are we deploying now do we
know about these things they're out
there line cubes I I wish that I could
plasma I wish I could remember the exact
um I wish I could remember the exact
example he gave me but when I had Jimmy
Aiken on my show yesterday he was
talking about the fact that there was a
fighter that the stealth fighter the
government was testing and people were
seeing it and they thought it was
extraterrestrial and the government was
basically like relieved and letting
people believe that because they didn't
want people to be on to their their
capabilities oh so that's probably why
this new disclosure came out yeah right
that's also a point he made right right
when the United States is getting
involved in one side of a conflict and
he was also saying that um the U.S sort
of wanted the USSR to think that we were
in contact with extraterrestrials so
that they would be afraid that we had
alien Firepower which is completely
insane but apparently there's like
actual records that the the government
was was interested in this strategy and
so you see this whistleblower who's
coming out and saying
um that you know we're studying this
craft that wasn't made by humans right
at the same time that we're getting
involved in this conflict between Russia
and Ukraine you think yeah maybe one
explanation here is it's a psyop and we
want the Russians to believe that we do
have an alien craft which is crazy to uh
The Men Who Stare at Goats yes right
that's that really happened though the
United States tried to trick the
Russians into thinking that we were
trying to develop telepathy so so then
the Russians heard that they said oh my
goodness America is trying so basically
did so they actually started doing it
and then we saw they were doing it and
we actually tried to start doing it we
Psy upped ourselves into trying to
develop telepathic methods did it work
no they tried to give people heart
attacks they tried to get these psychics
together to your earlier point the
channel energy but to give them heart
attacks maybe it didn't work and
apparently it didn't work or maybe it
did work yeah I heard that they teach
CIA assets not to if they're following
someone not to stare at the person
they're following because they'll give
the person a tendency to turn around
like you know when you're being watched
kind of thing yeah and that's not and
normal and apparently there are people
who have come out and said remote
viewing is real that the U.S military
worked on it and actually were able to
engage I was looking at I had a did a
bonfire a couple nights ago and I was
looking at the coals after the fire was
over and just like the way they were
moving and like all kind of glowing and
and senescence I don't know what the
right word is in essence it was like
dude I can see how ancient Shaman would
would stare into the coals and see
Visions because it like almost takes
your brain over man and you might just
see what you think you want to see but
it is that is a like a meditation oh
yeah yeah Ian keeps everybody here
honest yeah well no I mean Embers are it
is actually interesting just sort of the
the wave fire operates there's so much
Beauty in nature that I I think could be
misunderstood but that certainly like
lends itself to the the human mind
creating something more from it did you
guys uh watch the the CIA whistleblower
two days ago talk about the uh the alien
thing it's the most yeah I watched it
and it was like this guy's lying this is
obviously like the way he said he's like
I swear to God it happened like he
didn't say swear God he said something
uh like I it just it the way he uses he
used word that was like uh that was made
it very apparent that he was like lying
uh maybe we can watch it or bring it up
at some point I don't know I watched his
interview like 30 seconds long I didn't
get a chance to to see it he wasn't
convincing no he's right it was it was
more like trust me bro yeah like I did
the I saw it trust me bro no you don't
you're not gonna get any proof he wasn't
there have been more convincing
whistleblowers the only thing that
worked in his favor I think is that his
attorney was a pretty well respected guy
he was the dodig Inspector General who
is insisting that he believes him now
again I didn't believe him either but
he's certainly not this guy's a
government employee he's not making the
kind of money that that one would make
to retain an attorney like this if the
attorney thought it was all BS so it
makes you wonder why this guy would take
on the case why this guy would put his
reputation in front of it unless he was
read in to a different program and
they're using this as a disinformation
tool to throw the bad guys off okay that
makes a lot of sense like we're about to
start deploying some crazy stealth or
like uh energy weapon Tech over Ukraine
and they want him to think it's alien
yeah so you go to an old do dig guy who
probably still carries his clearance his
TS seis were reputable and you tell them
hey play ball here you were one of us
for a while help play ball here help
spread this and it serves its purpose
okay wait I found a clip it's hard to
find a lot it's only six seconds David
group believe it or not as fan as
Fantastical as that sounds
it's true and believe it or not I just
who says believe it or not when they're
trying to tell someone what happened and
believe it or not Tim it really happened
yeah
he's he's trying to convince the guy he
looks like every guy we locked up for
something who tried to convince us he
didn't do it well we were we were going
to segue from weather into culture War
issues and turn it to weather and Aliens
instead because you just can't control
where it goes so now we're gonna hard
segue back you can control the weather
you can if you sacrifice yeah or with
lasers or space silver silver iodide oh
yeah yeah not space lasers quite
literally just infrared lasers that are
used to seed to see clouds and they use
uh silver iodide as well and they've
done that since the 60s and it's really
funny that if you tell someone that the
government controls the weather the
implication is that you're crazy and
it's like we I learned this in grade
school right they like showed us a book
and there are cloud seating because it
works I think they do it over Dubai is
it they made it rain yeah they do that
and they and it was public I mean they
made a media event out of it there's no
secret there yeah it condenses all of
the water vapor in two clouds making
rain come down yeah I wanna start
controlling lightning I want to know
more about their lightning programs the
problem with lightning is that you can't
measure
the the the charge the voltage whatever
and so I was reading about why we don't
capture lightning energy to use and it's
like you can't measure it so you can't
store it properly you need to know you
know volts amps or whatever the power
that's coming through to be able to
accurately but you can't do that did you
guys see the the blue Sprites above
Earth's atmosphere when lightning
strikes it like sends a blue flame out
into space like the lightning comes down
and as it's coming down a piece of blue
flame goes out and up oh dude that's
great that does look very cool you're
looking at a blue Sprite you know have
you ever just just one more thing about
lightning before we move on it next time
there is a lightning storm where you are
get the slo-mo camera out on your iPhone
if you have one and just film it's crazy
to watch that in slow motion
don't
run into the gay Church
Lightning's spectacular man I love it
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time